uh what is your strategy to win the
brother canada so my strategy is just to
charm the pants off of everybody in the
house i just want to come in with that
sweet personality bubbly personality
that everybody's gonna love
amazing uh what kind of personality
would you clash with the most in the
house i think i'm going to clash with
somebody that is very rah-rah-rah loud
drama always just in the mix of all the
problems i try to stay away from that in
my regular life so i think that's
definitely someone i would clash with in
the house
i think that showmances definitely are
fun but you usually get clipped right
before the end so i think for myself i'm
gonna stay away from showmances and just
try to play my game a strong game on my
own
amazing um why is canada going to work
for you
canada's going to root for me because
i'm lovable i am that single mom that
you could relate to
that is strong and independent and
determined to win
and i just want to do this for all of
the strong single moms out there that
think that maybe they can't do something
well you can so i think that canada will
be on my side in that sense
you